- I'm just saying, I've
never seen one up close.
- Okay, why don't you let us
know in the YouTube Community
section if you think bald eagles are real.
See you next time on "Every Damn Day".
- [Director] Cut.
- [Chris] I mean, have
you seen a bald eagle?
- Wow guys, great show, great show.
Ryan, little less nose next time.
Just a quick note,
everybody: research says that
our show is in dire
need of a bad boy type.
- That's right, so you're gonna
give a little presentation
for the suits. Unless one of
you can prove that you're the
bad boy, we might have to
look into other options.
As in, replace you because
you're not good at your job.
Okay, good show!
(upbeat theme music)
- Hannah, why don't you start us off.
- This is so stupid, why
are we even doing this?
I'm clearly the baddest.
- State your case, then.
- I show up whenever I want,
I wear a leather jacket,
I put Four Loco in all of
the couch cushions, and
I've been replacing Ryan's
coffee with dip spit for weeks.
- The viewers don't believe
you're bad boy material.
- Why? Because I'm a woman?
- Yes. Our research shows
that our audience hates women
and want to make Comedy
Central great again. That means
bad boys, and saying the
phrase "I'm Rick James, (bleep)."
- This is bull (bleep).
- No it's not. It's backed by data.
- [Ryan] I'm going to get a new coffee.
- Don't be such a little (bleep).
(Chris laughs)
- I believe I misunderstood
the assignment.
(saxophone music)
- So, who ate my pasta salad?
- Me.
- Oh, excellent. No further
questions, your honor.
(knocks on the table)
- Shaving it bald and returning
it before they've noticed.
(laughs)
- Item 14, adult circumcision. Item 15 -
- We've seen enough.
- (bleep).
- What about the time I started the
trash fire in the office?
- Yeah, and because of that,
Name Tag Terry got promoted
to safety officer.
- Thanks, Hannah.
- Yeah, hi Name Tag Terry.
(saxophone music)
(stomach gurgles)
- Any pasta salad left?
(vomits)
- One part macaroni, three parts worms.
(spits)
- That's not a recipe.
- Okay, Ryan, you're last up.
- This is ridiculous.
- State your case.
- I have no case. I'm not
the bad boy, I don't want
to be the bad boy. I just
want to make a good show.
(whispering)
- Okay. We feel that
you're all pretty bad.
- Like, bad-bad. So we're
just gonna go with Ryan for
any bad boy stuff because
he's easiest to bully.
- Come on.
- Don't complain.
- Okay.
- There's a lot of talent in this room.
(vomits)
Call my dad.
- The macaroni is worms.
(cheerful electronic music)
- Okay, we asked you what we
should tattoo on Ryan's neck,
and you voted for Selena.
Let's see how it's going.
- [Ryan] I'm a good boy. I'm a good boy!
(jazz music)